dr jamie ogenstein with oasis animal
hospital in henderson joining us once
again for our pet vet segment today we
are talking
heartworm prevention lice other
parasites to start with dr ogenstein
before i met with you i didn't realize
that heartworm was something we actually
had to be concerned about here in
southern nevada
that's true i've lived here for many
years and we didn't really worry about
for a while
found out a few years ago they are here
in fact if you check the
companion animal parasite council
website there have been 42 cases
diagnosed in clark county
this year what do these worms physically
do to an animal we've got some video
we're sharing with our viewers here
so these are worms that live in the
heart and the pulmonary
vessels causing damage there and
ultimately untreated will cause
heart failure it's a pretty nasty
situation
yeah this can be fatal how do we stop
this from happening dr augie
you know that's actually pretty easy to
prevent it is so much cheaper and easier
to prevent and all you have to do is get
an annual blood test
make sure they don't have parasites and
then once you know they don't have
parasites you can actually start them on
the preventive which is either
an injection once a year called pro
heart or
you can actually give them a monthly
tablet that's chewable most dogs take it
like a treat
[Laughter]
mine does get a little excited for that
one and i've got it in my calendar for
the once a month thing
all right so you mentioned other
parasites let's tackle lice now with the
other parasites what do pet owners have
to keep in mind
so the other parasites some of them are
transmitted directly dog to dog
or cat to cat others have to go through
the intestinal tract meaning they get
transmitted through the feces
anytime you take your pet out you should
definitely be checking them you should
be checking
doing fecal tests but you have to just
be aware of your surroundings for your
pet know where they're going
look at what they're checking into look
at the around the surroundings where
they are
okay makes good sense and anything more
you would like to add today
uh just be aware of what's going on and
again you know if you see something on
your pet
and you question whether it's normal
take a picture of it
take it off your pet put in a little
baggie bring it to us because it's
always easier to
be able to see something and diagnose it
than
trying to go off of somebody's
description snapping pictures best thing
you could use a
smartphone for take a picture what you
see and let us see it
okay good to know well thank you so very
much for your time today
dr jamie ogenstein dr augie for short of
oasis animal hospital in henderson and
we look forward to chatting with you in
the next two weeks take care for now
thank you thank